In comparison to the multi-million dollar
star-studded display of excess that is the
modern day Academy Awards, the first Academy
Awards ceremony was a relatively muted affair
that could even be described as quaint if
you were so inclined.
Held in a medium-sized banquet hall in a Hollywood
hotel mostly known for being haunted today
(Hollywood Roosevelt Hotel), the May of 1929
event wasn’t even broadcast to the public
in any form.
As unbelievable as it may seem given how massively
popular the Academy Awards are today, the
idea of an awards ceremony to celebrate various
achievements in filmmaking was initially thought
to be absurd.
You see, few in Hollywood believed that any
members of the studios within the industry
would vote for anything but their own films.
As for the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences itself, it was a relatively new
organization, in part formed by producer Louis
B. Mayer in 1927 with the intent of uniting
the various branches of filmmaking, as well
as to try to curtail these entities from unionizing.
When it came to the Academy Awards themselves,
he also hoped this would similarly allow him
extra direct control over these groups.
As he would later state, “I found that the
best way to handle [filmmakers] was to hang
medals all over them … If I got them cups
and awards, they’d kill… to produce what
I wanted.
That’s why the Academy Award was created.”
Others in the Academy had less nefarious motives,
with the hope being that the Academy Awards
would lend more prestige and legitimacy to
the industry, helping to convince the public
to take this relatively new form of entertainment
more seriously.
So, yes- even from the beginning the Academy
Awards have always been about the individuals
working in movies trying to make it seem like
they are extremely important…
This all brings us around to the story of
Rin Tin Tin, a German shepherd dog that was
found in a half blown up kennel in France
during WWI by an American gunner named Lee
Duncan.
When Duncan came across the kennel, most of
the dogs inside were dead from the bombing
of the area, excepting one mother dog and
her five pups, two of which he kept for himself,
naming them Rin Tin Tin and Nanette.
(Named after little Rintintin and Nénette
yarn dolls often given as good luck charms
to soldiers and others fighting to free France.)
After the war, Duncan brought the two dogs
back to the states with him, with Rin Tin
Tin ultimately becoming a huge star in Hollywood,
prominently appearing in a whopping 27 films
during his career, almost singlehandedly popularizing
the German Shepard breed in America and playing
a large part in keeping the struggling Warner
Bros. afloat in the early days.
In the year leading up to the first Academy
Awards, he also starred in four hit films,
Jaws of Steel, A Dog of the Regiment, Tracked
by the Police, and Hills of Kentucky.
(You can watch Rin Tin Tin in action in that
one here, valiantly defending little Davey
from a pack of wolves).
So when said award ceremony came around, the
story goes that he, naturally, won best actor.
But as a huge point of the Academy Awards
was to try to make filmmakers and their films
seem more important and prestigious, having
a dog win one of the top awards didn’t sit
well with the organizers, so the Best Actor
award instead went to Emil Jannings.
Or, at least, this is the story off repeated
on the interwebs, even on some of the most
otherwise reputable sites.
So is it true?
Nope.
When the first Academy Awards were held in
1929, votes were cast well in advance and,
unlike today, weren’t kept a secret at all.
As a result, all of the winners (and losers)
that first year knew well ahead of time, as
did the public.
In fact, the LA Times published the results
about three months before the ceremony took
place.
From the fact that these ballots were public
(and they still exist in the archives at the
Academy’s Margaret Herrick Library), we
know definitively that Rin Tin Tin didn’t
even come close to winning Best Actor, receiving
only a single mocking vote by Warner Bros.
executive Jack Warner, contrary to what almost
literally every source we could find on the
matter states.
The genesis of the rumor that he not only
did receive many votes, but won, can be traced
back to a different Warner Bros. executive,
Darryl Zanuck.
He was one of many who initially thought the
Academy Awards were a stupid idea.
The story goes that when he first caught wind
of a ceremony celebrating Hollywood, Zanuck
wrote a letter to Academy executive Frank
Woods that including a faux ballot that only
nominated Warner Bros. features and workers
to demonstrate what he believed would happen
if the idea became reality- that everyone
would just vote for their own stuff.
He then further showed his contempt for the
idea by writing Rin Tin Tin’s name in for
Best Actor.
Zanuck (who actually became a strong proponent
for the awards in later years) evidently told
this story one too many times at a cocktail
party or two, leading to it becoming enshrined
in Hollywood lore and repeated ad nauseum,
which in turn resulted in the story ending
up in a 2011 book by Susan Orlean, Rin Tin
Tin: The Life and the Legend . The news media
picked up on this, spreading the legend as
fact, and seemingly few have bothered to look
into it from there.
The truth is that when official ballots were
actually cast, Zanuck didn’t even bother
voting, joking or not.
So, sadly, despite arguably being one of the
most popular stars in Hollywood and, by all
accounts, a very, very good boy, Rin Tin Tin
was completely snubbed by Hollywood insiders
thanks to their blatant and unapologetic speciesism.
And so it was that German actor Emil Jannings,
who would later go on to make many Nazi propaganda
films, was honored instead…
As for Rin Tin Tin, he remained a good boy
and, despite being a German (shepherd), never
appears to have had any Nazi leanings.
On top of that, he doesn’t appear to have
ever discriminated against anyone based on
their species, race, nor seemingly had any
prejudices of any kind, except (presumably)
a deep loathing
of mailmen.